I have not seen this part of glow yet
I've liked what I've seen but I have not
seen I'm told you have a part of glow
where you are nude nude acting I'm the
one guy in a cat no there's two of us
but there's 14 women in me and they're
all signed in these nudity things were
they they've got a sign to say that
they'll do some nudie it would be unfair
if I said I wouldn't do it so I said I'd
do it then my day came you know where
they're like all right it's it's you're
gonna do nudity today I'm like can we
not do the front would that be okay can
we not they're like I'm not ashamed of
it but it's a little much I don't need
that meme out in the world you know what
I mean like I like I don't need this to
go on the air and then see my dick in a
million places on Twitter so I'm good
with the but we can do the butt so they
did the right thing they did I did it
like a butt shot yeah but you still
you're naked and you have to wear this
like this sock like there's a little
pouch on your thing yeah I don't know
what I can and can't say I can say right
you know you gotta wear
[Applause]
you've got this thing broke a while ago
and I decided to just sit here tonight
wearing this but you could say whatever
you want around this set with this
little pouch for a penis yeah and you're
sort of like this made you look more
stupid than it would normally maybe I
should just take it out right
but I didn't are you proud of your nude
scene did it come out all right yeah I
thought my butt looked pretty good
yeah yeah I mean here's the sad part of
it before I had to do it I took selfies
of my butt you know just to be like okay
no blemishes I think I'm okay can I have
some butt selfies back in that I can use
this I want they're still in your phone
yeah you want to see him no I do
you